von der Weile habe ich auf meinen
zweitkanal ein Video hochgeladen mit dem
Titel der einfachste Elektromotor der
Welt der besteht aus der Batterie
Magneten und etwas Draht und
funktioniert wirklich aber hat halt
wirklich null Kraft der Wind so ist so
krass das sind Witz kaum was in diesem
Video bauen wir jetzt also einen
richtigen Elektromotor der Ultra viel
Kraft hat laut unseren Berechnungen
sollte der Motor wenn er fertig ist über
10 PS haben also viel wie zwei
Motorroller und irgendwann sollte auch
noch ein E-Bike oder ein Gokart
betreiben
dieses Video wird unterstützt von Nvidia
und MIFcom von denen auch mein PC ist
mit dem ich hier auf dem Kanal schon
einiges an 3D Konstruktion Rendering
Simulation und Videoschnitt gemacht habe
und der auch beim Design des
Elektromotors natürlich wieder zum
Einsatz kommt eigentlich habe ich schon
mal ein Elektromotor selbst gebaut und
zwar vor zwei Jahren aus Versehen in dem
Video Stromgenerator selber bauen in
einer Woche aber um das zu verstehen
müssen wir das Video noch mal kurz
reinschauen wie schwer wäre es von den
absolut wie nicht im Ernstfall aus total
grundlegenden baute Generator zu bauen
hier gleichzeitig reindrückt dann passen
die hier perfekt rein das heißt ich kann
jetzt das Teil hier drüber legen und
dann schon mal drehen und das generiert
schon mal Strom und jetzt habe ich noch
eine Idee mein Plan ist nämlich jetzt
nicht nur eine Seite mit Magnete zu
haben sondern aber direkt von beiden
Seiten das sorgt für ein stärker als
Magnetfeld mal schauen ob die Zeile
etwas gebracht hat
hat das gebracht wir kommen auf 15 Volt
was schon in 10 ist und wir haben diesen
alten Generator sogar noch in
irgendeiner Kiste gefunden und in die
Gegenwart gebracht wir wissen jetzt also
das Magneten die an so einem Kupferdraht
vorbei zwischen einfach Strom rein
zaubern komplett krass aber so ein
Generator ist auch direkt Motor weil
dann stelle das Teil zu drehen und dann
Strom rauszubekommen können wir auch
einfach hier Strom reingeben und dann
eine Drehung rausbekommen und damit
irgendwie Reifen oder ein Propeller
anzutreiben jeder dieser Spulen da drin
ist nämlich ein Elektromagnet Strom
drauf gibt entsteht Magnetfeld das
andere Magneten entweder anzieht oder
abstößt das gleiche Phänomen habe ich in
meinem Video namens unendlichen
Kreislauf bauen genutzt wir schauen mal
rein bei meiner Variante soll es quasi
einen Trichter geben indem man eine
Murmel rein wird die dann auf eine
Murmelbahn rollt Anlauf nimmt und durch
die spezielle Biegung wieder zurück in
den Trichter geschossen wird jetzt
können wir die Physik realistisch
simulieren und da sieht man eindeutig
dass da wieder eine Murmel oben
rauskommt mit Schwung das Haus hinten
und vorne nicht hin und jetzt kommt der
Zaubertrick der natürlich eigentlich
überhaupt keiner ist und das zum laufen
zu bringen wird sie extrem beschleunigt
das Problem ist dass die Kugel nur zu
dem Magneten hingeschleunigt wird
richtig cooles machen
und schon hat man immer ein paar Strom
an und ausschalten kann hoffentlich
ist ja geil
[Musik]
und wieder an simuliert habe ich das
damals übrigens in Nvidia omnivers mit
meiner RTX 3090 mittlerweile habe ich
eine RTX 4090 tun wir das was ich jetzt
vor habe noch viel flüssiger gehen Ich
will euch jetzt nämlich in 3D
demonstrieren wie aus diesem Generator
wird zuerst habe ich dafür dass 3D
Modell von Generator aus dem
CAD-Programm als Punkt USD Datei
exportiert und die ziehe ich jetzt in
den Nvidia omniverse USD composer
omnivers beinhaltet selbst Software
ermöglicht es aber auch andere Programme
wie Blender Maya oder die Epic Games
Unreal Engine miteinander zu verbinden
und zusammen als Team zu nutzen es geht
also darum dreidimensionale virtuelle
Welten zu bauen egal ob für Filme
Computerspiele oder virtuelle Kopien der
echten Welt für Augmented Reality oder
eben für eine Veranschaulichung für
Youtube Video ich habe hier jetzt
hübschen Raum erstellt und den Generator
noch die richtigen Materialien verpasst
und schon steht der Generator
fotorealistisch da und sieht toll aus
aber es ist eben auch nicht nur
Generator sondern auch Motor denn auf
dieser Scheibe sind super viele Spulen
und jede einzelne ist ein Elektromagnet
genau wie der den wir vorhin gesehen
haben man kann ihn also ein und
ausschalten indem man Strom drauf geht
das hier ist der rotieren Teil des
Motors und da sind ganz viele
Permanentmagnete drauf also Magnete die
man nicht erst an und ausschalten muss
normale Magnete eben wir blenden mal
alle aus bis auf jeweils 1 und dann wird
die Funktionsweise eigentlich recht
schnell klar denn wenn man jetzt auf die
Spule Strom mit positiver Spannung gibt
entsteht durch die Spule ein Magnetfeld
das dann den Permanentmagnet anzieht und
weil der an der Achse befestigt ist kann
der ja nur in die eine Richtung und
dreht sich samt Axel nach rechts wenn
der Magnet an der Spule vorbeigeflitzt
ist wird durch die Spule statt vorher
einer positiven jetzt eine negative
Spannung gejagt dass Magnetfeld der
Spule wird also umgepolt und der
Permanentmagnet nicht mehr angezogen
sondern abgestoßen und dadurch weiter
nach rechts gedrückt und damit der nicht
irgendwann den Schwung verliert haben
wir ganz viele Spulen und passend zu den
vielen Spuren auch viele Magnete weil
dadurch der Motor einfach viel mehr
Power hat in den Motor sowie wir ihn
hier sehen sind dann meistens noch
mehrere Spulen miteinander verbunden zu
insgesamt drei Gruppen auf Phasen
genannt damit diese Spulen jeweils immer
gleichzeitig angesteuert werden diese
ganzen Animation hat man ein Video hast
du die PC mit der RTX 40 90
eigentlich sie zu 3d-zeuge immer super
stumpf aus solange man dran arbeitet und
sieht erst cool aus wenn man es dann auf
wenn ich rendert das geht jetzt hier
eben in Echtzeit und sieht schon geil
aus während andere arbeitet und ich
hatte da war einfach permanent über 100
FPS wenn ihr euch jetzt denkt dass es
verdammt schwierig ist diese ganze
elektromagnetische hier immer genau in
der Sekunde anzuschalten wenn gerade
zufällig ein anderer Magnet dran vorbei
ist dann habt ihr verdammt recht dafür
gibt's zum Glück ein Bauteil einen
sogenannten ESC der schickt hier an
diese drei Phasen abgesprochen haben
genau zum richtigen Zeitpunkt den
richtigen Strom und damit will ich jetzt
versuchen bevor wir später eine richtig
krassen erstmal diesen alten Generator
als Motor zu benutzen dann stelle ich
das jetzt hier rein egal wo da meine
Batterie rein jo
man hört was okay ich habe das noch mal
ein bisschen mit weniger Reibung
gelagert also dreht sich jetzt schon mal
frei
oh er bewegt sich ich würde sagen das
Motor
oh Alter da fehlt nur noch so ein
bisschen was ne ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher dass ich weiß woran es liegt und
zwar dass das Magneten zu spulen fällt
ist einfach falsch ist für Motor anstatt
dass ich den alten Generator jetzt
modifiziert also wieso nicht wirklich
die Chance hat richtig viel Power zu
haben bauen wir einfach direkt den
fetten Motor der auch wirklich gut wird
und so soll dieser Motor Aussehen ein
ähnliches Design wie unser alter
Generator aber erstens deutlich größer
zweitens bestehen die Spulen aus viel
dickeren dritten und haben den Eisenkern
in der Mitte wodurch deren Magnetfeld
deutlich verstärkt wird und der Motor
dadurch mehr Power hat drittens viel
größere und stärkere Permanentmagneten
viertens einem anderen Verhältnis
zwischen Permanentmagneten und Spulen
was deren Anzahl angeht und fünftens das
Ding ist deutlich präziser und stabiler
weil ihr fast alles aus Aluminium
gemacht werden soll und nicht aus
Plastik und mit diesem Auto Teilen
fangen wir jetzt auch an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die Teile sind jetzt wirklich absolut
massiv hier kommt später die Magneten
rein wir kümmern uns aber erstmal um den
statischen Teil da kommen auch die
Spuren dran die wickeln wir jetzt gleich
selber aus diesem Kupferdraht dann sieht
er glaube ich ganz anschaulich wie viel
mächtiger die sind im Vergleich zu den
von unserem Generator der Dicke gerade
Eisenteil drauf gewickelt und davon
brauchen wir jetzt erstmal 12 Uhr
los
die müssen da noch ein bisschen
geschliffen werden
[Musik]
dann bekommen sie alle in Loch
reingebohrt
[Musik]
in das dann Gewinde reingeschnitten wird
und auf die andere Seite
drauf geschweißt
[Musik]
oder so ein Teil wickeln wir jetzt den
Kupferdraht Pascal dafür so eine richtig
heftige Gerätschaft gebaut
wieso oft später weil Sekundenkleber
eine sehr große Rolle
so das müssen jetzt 145 Wicklungen sein
und die muss ich einfach mitzählen okay
also wir haben jetzt aktuell 1 2
4 16A
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
folgendes geht jetzt mal Strom drauf
aktuell wenn ich das jetzt hier drauf
macht passiert gar nichts wenn ich aber
jetzt Strom drauf geht dann ist halt weg
ist das wäre ganz normal nur dass ich
den hier einfach ausschalten kann
der Teil des Motors ist also fertig ich
habe das mal ein bisschen vorgespult die
sind auch verkabelt ich denke das
griechische sind wir nicht dann wird das
Teil aber später explodieren oder mal
zumindest abbrennen also wirklich massiv
schwer mittlerweile also das Teil liegt
mittlerweile
drei Kilo und ich sage euch das meiste
davon ist halt einfach Kupfer weil das
Auto weg kaum was und wir haben gut die
Eisen keine Dinge natürlich
kommen wir zum sich drehen Teil wenn man
jetzt mal Vergleich mit den Magneten von
unserem kleinen Generator dann sieht man
jo Alter das die größten mäßig ein
bisschen heftiger sind und ich habe
schon ausprobiert also die Dinger sind
so stark wenn du die irgendwie an
Eisenbahn kriegst kriegst du den nicht
mehr ab das ist richtig krass
Alter genau die müssen jetzt rein mit
dem ersten das ist ziemlich genau
so rein ich glaube auch dass wir eine
Schraubzwingen brauchen könnten
sogar rein jo das ist komplett drin
nicht wundern ich mache jetzt die
Klebeband drüber damit er nicht überall
Eisenspäne drauf landen
so kommt es ist mega wichtig weil wenn
er einmal drin ist kriegt nie wieder
raus dass man die abwechselnd drauf
macht gar keinen Bock auf den anderen
hätte der extrem viel Bock aber so
falsch
[Musik]
also man muss die Magneten so ein
bisschen dazu zwingen das jetzt zu
machen mit dem davon selber nicht so
richtig Lust drauf
ich habe es überlebt der nächste Schritt
ist jetzt quasi dass man diese Scheibe
und diese Scheibe relativ nah aneinander
kriegt und so dass ich eins davon über
Kugellager dreht
auf geht's
[Musik]
12 run detection okay jetzt wird sehr
spannend jetzt sollte ich eigentlich
schon bewegen ich habe ein bisschen
Angst ich habe voll Löcher auf jeden
Fall schon bereitgestellt boah er bewegt
sich als ob no way ist das krass der
Land ist quasi gerade den Motor erstmal
an ja hat er jetzt gemacht so also mach
mal gleich einen Fähnchen dran damit man
hier erkennen kann wie sich der dreht
und jetzt gehe ich mal ein bisschen Gas
sich nicht aber er dreht sich
also es ist zweifelsohnen Motor kann
keiner was dagegen sagen und das auch
selber gemacht er dreht sich jetzt
leider nicht schneller als das hat gut
Power aber ist natürlich noch nicht
perfekt also damit kann man jetzt kein
E-Bike betreiben oder so das ist aber
was für ein anderes Video wenn ihr jetzt
einen neuen PC braucht und hauptsächlich
damit arbeiten aber manchmal eben auch
das neueste Game zocken wollt kann ich
euch in den Videos Studio PC vorschlagen
den ihr über den Link in der
Videobeschreibung bei mir kommt findet
mit dem modernen 40er Grafikkartenserie
von Nvidia braucht ihr übrigens selbst
unter höchst Last weniger Strom als
ältere Modelle und wenn er bei mir kommt
dann im PC sieht der euch gefällt könnt
ihr den sogar ganz nach euren Wünschen
anpassen und zum Beispiel sagen hey mir
wird hier vielleicht auch ein schlichtes
Gehäuse reichen aber hier brauche ich
auf jeden Fall eine extra Festplatte
unten ein bisschen mehr ran das ganze
wird dann fertig zusammengebaut bei euch
zu Hause angeliefert und Support und
Garantie gibt natürlich auch immer
kostenlos dabei sind die ein Video hast
du die Treiber für optimale Performance
bei allen möglichen Programm z.B von das
was damit von mir macht's gut